where do you put the importance of some
of these uh ideas at the founding of the
united states
when then
now we're talking about at the context
of china the freedom of speech freedoms
what china is doing with the central
management of a lot of things it's
enabling a lot of growth
but it's also limiting
people on the very basic level in terms
of freedom the kind of freedom that
i think can lead to entrepreneurship to
starting new businesses to having big
dreams and chasing those dreams and then
creating totally new things in whatever
the space maybe in technology
in in business and whatever
uh what how important is that as a
metric for society well they have a view
which is the idea of a dialectic which
means that two things are at obvious
that everything comes with pros and cons
and two opposites
exist and you want the benefits of those
two opposites and how do you deal with
the benefits of those two opposites
right so
let's say you want the capital markets
because it gets um money into the hands
of the entrepreneurs who are motivated
they build fortunes and that drives an
economy to do very well and at the same
time
it produces
the other problems the wealth gaps the
other problems then the debt cycle that
we're talking about and so on and deng
xiaoping you know how do you reconcile
communism
and
um the market economy and the capital
markets and he uh famously said um
and if it doesn't matter if it's a white
cat or a black cat just as long as it
catches mice
in other words if it if it works in
making the country richer
then that becomes the objective and then
they move that along so there are these
conflicts
um and um
one of the leaders
described it to me as follows because
it's confusion and it goes back over a
period of time
there's a a hierarchy and it's an
extension of the family he described it
and he said the united states is a
country
of individuals and individualism
and that is its vibrancy that
we see
the individual
rights to speak up the individual
[Music]
protection of the individual individual
property rights and all of those things
as of uh paramount importance and we
build our organization that's why
democracy is from the bottom up or even
a company we'll get together and we'll
be partners to proper prosper together
that is the american approach
um he was describing that in china it's
an extension of the confucian family
essentially and so it's almost like um
you know there's a hierarchy and so what
they think about is the common good
uh not the individualism
so for example if they want a high-speed
rail to go from one place to another and
that's best in the common good
then the individual protections that
would stand in the way of doing that
would be of secondary concern
so that notion of uh controlling so it
for example
um the what what they're doing with uh
video games
um
they um control
uh what type of video games and how
many hours a day kids can be on video
games um
operating in that way because they
believe that that's good for the society
and that's very controlling
in the united states i i think probably
most parents would say leave it to me
and it's it's a matter between me and my
kids the same thing has to do with data
in other words in the united states who
controls the data
does the company control the data do you
individually control the data and so the
inclination would be to figure that out
but nobody would say that the government
is going to control the data because of
our inclination of really
anti-government control in china it
would be that the government will
control the data because that's going to
be best for the society and it depends
who you trust but that's
so that difference in philosophy is very
much at the um you know at the heart of
that as far as um your question in terms
of
effectiveness it really is
in china's case it's how you balance the
things right so what they're attempting
to do is to create a lot of freedom and
creativity um in areas that are not
uh political let's say um
and um and so you see on a lot of
entrepreneurship you see a lot of
product development you see a lot of
creativity
um happening in that way so the
stereotype that you don't see creativity
happening is is an old stereotype
where's a lot of creativity certainly
happening and the system can work well
if they can achieve that kind of balance
it's proven to work well since i started
going there in 1984 per capita income
real per capita income has increased by
26 times the um longevity rate is
increased by 10 years the poverty rate
has fallen from 88 percent to less than
one percent in terms of you know basics
like starvation and things and if you
read history
plato's republic you know he talks about
the cycles
democracy
you know and autocratic and the
benevolent
despot and all of that
um each has um their own vulnerability
the vulnerability of democracy which has
been a remarkable remarkable system and
i don't have to extol the benefits of it
um but the vulnerability of it
has always been uh the um internal
conflict that produces itself as anarchy
um in world war ii
uh four democracies
chose to be
autocracies
um because there was internal disorder
and there was this the belief will
somebody bring about order and get
control of the situation you know that
was in um germany italy uh japan and
spain um they were parliamentary dictate
um systems that turned themselves over
to that so both systems
have
vulnerabilities um
i think the main thing that we need to
think about
is those vulnerabilities democracy is an
amazing system because it
the the adherence to the rules and the
system and the checks and balances is
quite amazing and it gives it a
flexibility to change without civil wars
but there has to be the respect of the
rules and when you see something like um
they will not
accept
elections or they will not accept rules
and history has shown when the causes
that people are behind are more
important to them than the system the
system is in jeopardy
you